el gobierno francés está introduciendo
una serie de medidas para aumentar el
poder adquisitivo de sus habitantes un
plan que está previsto para iniciar el
primero de agosto y tiene como objetivo
ayudar a los hogares a hacer frente al
aumento de los precios el salario mínimo
subirá más del 2.01 por ciento a mil 329
euros por mes o cerca de los nueve euros
por hora los empleados públicos verán un
aumento de sus salarios del 3.5 por
ciento beneficiando a unos 6 millones de
personas el interés de las cuentas de
ahorro denominadas libreta reguladas por
el gobierno subirá al 2 por ciento
también se potenciarán varias
prestaciones de la seguridad social los
adultos discapacitados recibirán un
aumento del 4% en los pagos de los
beneficios al igual que las personas que
reclaman el subsidio de búsqueda de
empleo y las que tienen becas para
estudiantes finalmente el gobierno
francés extenderá desde el 31 de julio
hasta el 31 de agosto un descuento al
combustible de 15 a 18 céntimos por
litro
luego el descuento se incrementará de 18
a 30 céntimos por litro en septiembre y
octubre pero luego bajará a 10 céntimos
en noviembre